قلت في جلسة الاستماع الخاصة بك السيد الوزير إنك تعتقد أن الحكومة الصينية ضللت العالم بشأن فيروس كورونا بالنظر إلى أنه يجب معاقبة الملايين من الأشخاص الذين لقوا حتفهم في جميع أنحاء العالم بالطبع على ذلك وأعتقد أن المشكلة بالنسبة لنا هي تأكد من أننا نفعل كل ما هو ممكن لمنع جائحة آخر حتى ونحن نعمل من خلال هذا أه أو على الأقل للتأكد من أننا نستطيع التخفيف من أه بطرق أكثر فاعلية من أي ضرر يحدث إذا حدث شيء ما في المستقبل و جزء كبير من ذلك هو التأكد من أن لدينا نظامًا مطبقًا بما في ذلك مع منظمة الصحة العالمية التي تتميز بالشفافية التي تتميز بمشاركة المعلومات التي تتميز بالوصول للخبراء الدوليين في بداية شيء كهذا ، وهذا هو المكان الذي أعتقد أن الصين تحبها البلد لديه التزامات حقيقية يحتاج إلى الوفاء بها ، لذا أعتقد أن ما نحتاج إلى التركيز عليه هو التأكد من أننا نحمي بلادنا  lves
وحماية العالم
للمضي قدمًا
وسيتطلب ذلك الكثير من
الإصلاح وسيتطلب من الصين
القيام بأشياء لم تفعلها في
الماضي